جانب مما تدعو اليه بكين يتعلق بالعقبات
الامريكيه على الرقائق واشباه الموصلات
لكن هذه العقوبات دفعت الشركات الصينيه
لتطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي بطريقتها فكما
يقال ربما داره في التقرير خاص يجون
للقاله فيه ان الشركات الصينيه تدرس
تقنيات تسمح لها بتحقيق اداء ذكاء اصطناعي
متطور باشباه موصلات اقل قوه بحسب التقرير
من بين الشركات التي تعمل على هذا النسق
هواوي وعلي بابا والتي تحاول استخراج
فائده اكبر من رقائق الكمبيوتر الحاليه
ومع احتدام السباق لصنع نماذج شبيهه بتشات
جي بي تي
استبعدت الصين من الحصول على رقائق من اي
مئه وهي
انفيديا هي الاكثر شهره في تطوير الذكاء
الاصطناعي والجيل التالي هو اتش 100 الذي
تم اصداره في مارس الماضي لذلك تعمل
العديد من الشركات الصينيه على الجمع بين
ثلاث او اربع شرائح اقل تقدما لمحاكاه
اداء اقوى معالجات
انفيديا في ابريل كشفت تانسنت عن مجموعه
من الشرائح المتصله لتدريب نموذج ذكاء
اصطناعي على نطاق واسع اما شركه هواوي فقد
تمكنت من تطوير نموذج اولي للذكاء
الاصطناعي باسم بانجو سيجما
بان وصل بانجو وصل الى داء متطور في بعض
مهام اللغه الصينيه بما في ذلك فهم
القراءه والتحديات النحويه وغيرها دون
الاستعانه برقائق الفيديو لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات